Magnus you ready for this uh I've never
done this before so I wouldn't know
to give the challengers a Fighting
Chance Magnus played blindfolded forcing
him to visualize the three chess games
in his mind while playing against the
clock board one E4
as the match progressed Magnus showed no
signs of struggle as he called out his
moves without hesitation board one
Bishop E3 all the challengers are deep
in thought
The Challengers began to feel the
pressure I was risky Knight D5 check
made the next group board
The Challengers began to fall that is
Checkmate on board three that is one
down
forward one Queen takes after seven
seconds
I resign black has resigned on board one
and the time is up black has run out of
time Magnus wins on all boards